hi i'm david carlson and i'm an
assistant professor at duke university
i'm going to be talking today about
learning electrical connectomes of
neuropsychiatric disorders and behaviors
i wanted to begin by framing the
research goal i'm particularly
interested in understanding networks of
the brain and how they relate to
behaviors or neuropsychiatric conditions
my lab is developing explainable
artificial intelligence techniques that
learn networks of neural activity that
are biomarkers for several conditions
these techniques need to explain
themselves to communicate with the main
experts and one of the things that i'm
really passionate about is moving beyond
just the statistical analysis and
actually using the artificial
intelligence tools as a partner in
experimental design so we've already
used our machine learning methods to
learn testable hypotheses from data and
we've partnered with the
collective for neuropsychiatric
engineering led by kathleen deraza to
design and run experiment on these
hypotheses
so moving forward i'm first going to
highlight some of the properties of my
machine learning approaches and models
and then i'll explain a study that we
did in partnership with kapu duraza
where we actually use these explainable
ai tools to derive hypotheses and
actually design confirmatory experiments
so i wanted to begin by just setting up
uh how we're viewing our emotions here
and how we're going to be viewing
emotions as coming from differently
networks of the brain
for example you can have a fear of
motion and we're going to assume that
that is going to come from a latent
network corresponding to sphere when you
experience fear that means that there's
a biological neural network that is
activated and producing that emotion
this idea has been in the literature
before and it's been explored several
times in imaging studies of the brain
for example in this craving at all study
they asked humans to self-report
emotions and they used fmri to decode
emotions with fairly high accuracy
the key result for us here is that there
are clearly different neural activations
under each emotional condition so
different part of the brain is activated
and communicating under each emotional
condition here and you can see that on
the left here where you can see some of
the different emotional setups so for
example contentment is in red and you
can see the part of the brain that is
activated when you are content
um and you get different parts of the
brain that are activated under
these different emotions
and so this is kind of the basis that
we're thinking about here that emotions
really are latent networks
in our studies we're going to be
interested in network representations of
different emotions or conditions in
animal models and we're really
interested in animal models because
we're going to be able to do a lot more
interventions there
um unlike humans animals cannot
self-report so we're left with this
challenge that we cannot differentiate
differentiate between mass emotion
simply by looking at them or by asking
them this leads to a challenge that we
need to find some way of identifying
networks that correspond to our emotions
or neuropsychiatric risk so we're
looking at this we have this problem
where we need to think about how we can
use behaviors and training data in order
to help guide us to what we're looking
at in our emotions
the other thing that we're going to be
looking at is we're going to be looking
at what's called local field potentials
in particular we're interested in fairly
fast and temporally precise network
properties
right so these local field potentials
are going to come from implanted electro
electrodes and these electrodes are
going to be all over the brain
and each electrode is going to capture
the low frequency pattern when we're
looking at a low frequency pattern
inside the brain in a particular brain
region we're going to call this a local
field potential this is very highly
related to the eeg that you can record
outside the brain it looks similar but
it's a lot more
spatially precise and it's a lot higher
fidelity
and in addition we also get high
frequency information which you can use
to calculate things like action
potentials from different neurons which
i'm going to ignore for now and focus
instead on the lsps
so what i'm showing you here on the last
is i'm showing you for each of the
different brain regions that was
implanted i'm showing you a local field
potential trace
now this local field potential traits
we're assuming that there's one for
brain region if we have multiple wires
in a brain region we're just going to
average them to get a single local field
potential and we're going to do this for
reliability this loses a little bit of
information but we're really interested
in networks that hold up across
individuals or across the animals and so
in that case we think that the least
resolvable unit is a brain region and
that's where we can get consistency and
reliable information that is the same
across these different individuals
so lfps have been used kind of
historically in a lot of different ways
they're believed to reflect the sum of
activity from many neurons within a
brain region
and people have used them to say
take them and break them down into
different brain waves so for example you
might have your
um
you have your theta and your beta and
your delta
and you have different types of brain
waves here that represent different
properties of the neurons right so if we
think about the fact that we have these
local field potentials if we come up
with a network over local field
potentials we're going to believe that
they're going to reflect broad
properties of neurons
so what we need to do is we need to
figure out some way of capturing the
important information of the local field
potential people historically have used
these power features in different
frequency bands
now for our analysis because we're
interested in networks of the brain
we're really interested in saying
when these brain regions are
communicating
so
we really need to capture properties
that give us this communication so in
particular we're going to need to
capture it in different frequency bands
so what i'm showing you here is i'm
showing you the hippocampus and i'm
showing you just filter to a particular
frequency band and i'm showing you the
prefrontal cortex filtered to a
particular frequency band
now one of the things that people have
looked at historically is just
whether they have similar patterns right
so the hippocampus and the prefrontal
cortex have similar patterns this means
that they are functionally connected in
some sense that they are communicating
in some manner that might be direct
communication it might be a non-direct
communication for example you have
something upstream that's sending them
both the same information
and this is a measure of communication
and one of the things that we really
want in our network is not just whether
two brain regions are correlated but
actually are these two brain regions
sending information to one another in
this frequency band
and so we can think about that by coming
up with these measures of directionality
so we can think about what it would mean
for the hippocampus to be sending
information to the prefrontal cortex so
we take our hippocampus here and we say
it's sending information to the
prefrontal cortex we think that if
there's a temporal lag and then the
peaks kind of match up really cleanly
with what's going on in the hippocampus
then we think the hippocampus is sending
information to the prefrontal cortex now
if we look at the setup here we think
that this is uh matching a little bit
but not exactly that perfect whereas if
we look at the alternative relationship
it actually matches up a little bit
better where this is the idea where we
might be sending information from the
prefrontal cortex to hippocampus
now i'm sketching this out here
just by drawing lines and showing you
that these peaks are lining up in
interesting ways and the information
might be
flowing from one direction to the other
based on temporal lags
so when we're defining mathematical
networks we're not going to be using
these kind of conceptual plots we're
going to formalize this based off
something called granger causality but
the really the key point here
is that we believe our networks need to
capture directional flow of information
and we think this is really important
for when we start to go to develop our
hypotheses of how these networks are
actually working
so
the way we actually go about doing this
is by defining our networks and i want
to start by showing you what a network
actually looks like in our analysis this
is a network related to stress
because we are modeling the electrical
signals of the brain we call this
network the electrical connectome or
electron network the electron captures
the spectral or frequency properties of
the brain including the power coherence
and directionality properties
so on the bottom left we have a circle
plot and each brain region is
represented by different wedge so for
example up at the top left of the circle
plot we have vta or the ventral
tegmental area
each brain region has in there
these numbers that say 10 20 30 40 50
this is the frequency in hertz we're
breaking it down into frequency band a
mark on the outside on of the circle
plot indicates that that power is much
higher than background levels in the
brain when this network is active
so we think that when this network is
active there's power at about the eight
hertz or two to eight hertz band in the
ventral tegmental area
if there are
lines connecting to brain regions we say
that this is coherence that they are
communicating in some manner
so you can see here that we have a lot
of lines connecting all the brain
regions in this particular network on
this network in the brain regions that
were measured we kind of get
communication everywhere that's not
always the case
and we really see a lot of lines and
we've colored the lines here blue and
magenta and this really just to help us
know that there are two frequency bands
that were picked up by this electron
network so the blue band here is at the
2 to 8 hertz frequency band
and the magenta is at the 12 to 20 hertz
frequency band so not only can we view
which regions are involved in this
network we really want to use that idea
of this directionality to think about
how information may be flowing in the
network
so when we think about the lecture
network we have these frequency patterns
and then we can go over here to the
right and say well
what are the leading regions where do we
think this signal is actually
originating in this network
well we think this is in the 2 to 8
hertz frequency band in blue we believe
that the primary leaders of this are il
and the prelimbic cortex which you can
see from the arrows beneath it and then
the 12 to 20 hertz band it's a nucleus
accumbens
right this directionality is again
really important when we develop capable
hypotheses which i'll expand on later
but the really key property here is that
i can actually go and say hey this is a
network related to stress and i can go
to a collaborator that's a
neuroscientist and say this is a network
that i found that's related to stress
what do you think of this does this make
sense to you or are there things that
don't make sense to you and i believe
that this communication is really
important this back and forth
so
in practice we don't have just one thing
going on we're never going to exactly
see only the stress network we're not
going to see exactly only one network
we're going to have lots of things going
on at once the brain does many things at
once right so for example right now i am
talking and thinking about what i'm
going to say next i'm in a good mood
because i get to talk about fun science
i really like all this stuff and i'm
pretty tired because i have two young
kids at the home in the middle of a
pandemic there's a lot of other things
going on in my life that are in my brain
right now and are affecting me in
different ways so the model that we're
going to be using here is that each one
of these brain activities has a separate
electron networks so we have lots of
different electrical networks in our
brain
and the brain activity at any point in
time is going to be the superposition of
each brain network
multiplied by how strongly it's
expressed so for example f1 here may
represent our happiness network how
happy am i so when i'm really happy the
strength of that as w1
is going to be large right and it's
going to show up a lot in my neural
activity
and when i'm not as happy in that window
w it's going to be much lower and so
really this is a key model that we're
going to be using here each latent
function has a network that we care
about
and we just combine our activity to get
our brain observations
and if we do this we can actually go
back to our problem about different
emotional representations so if we think
about this emotional representation here
well what we can do is we can say well
each one of these different emotions has
a different electron network
and at any point in time we can actually
look at your neural activity and say
based upon the network properties and
the data we actually observed we can
estimate how happy you are how sad you
are how humoral you are and we can do
this by just visualizing each one of
these electrons and just mapping the
data so the way we actually do this in
practice
is by using something called a factor
analysis model
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
simplify data from each window
and we're going to say each window here
is yw
yw has c channels with t samples
and each window of data that we're going
to use here is a few seconds of data in
our applications
we need to capture things that are
relatively fast paced but not too fast
we're typically using a window of one to
five seconds
so what we're going to do is we're going
to map this to a small number of factors
so we're going to say our observed
neural activity
is going to be the superposition of
swk so that is the weight in window w of
electron network k multiplied by dk
which is going to represent our case
electron network
so this decay is shared through all of
time and this swk is a factor score away
and we're going to have a model
mismatched term as well but the big idea
here is that if we have our observed
neural data if we know what our
electrons are we can actually estimate
the vector of weight sw
really well so we can take our big
complicated local field potential data
map it into a small set of numbers that
represents what's going on in your brain
at that given point in time which we
often refer to as a brain state
now the big thing that we really need to
talk about
is to say that we need to ensure
features are interpretable right so i've
talked a lot about i want to go from
just using machine learning to analyze a
problem to using machine learning to
develop hypotheses and actually test
them so if we're going to do that we
need to be able to communicate what's
going on and so we have to force that
these features are interpretable so if
we use that approach that i gave before
where we said we have this dk and it's
just a vector of numbers if you just do
that out of the box you typically don't
get an interpretable structure so we
worked really hard on coming up with
approaches where we can actually get
interpretability so one of the things
that we require is that our factor
scores are non-negative so we we require
that there's no negative network that we
can observe
um and we're going to say that well
rather than using dk directly we're
going to use something called a latent
function factor analysis
so what happens is we define a model
that has the properties of the electrum
network so we have those special
properties and we have those power and
phase
coherence properties and then for each
window we're actually going to say we're
going to have f
w k here and f w k is now allowed to
change slightly for window but it's
going to be forced to share that
electron network so that's actually
going to be generated from the electron
network this seems to add a fair amount
of complexity here because it seems like
there's a lot more to explain now and
you have to be really careful in the way
you do this but in this is an
established model and it's something
that we've worked really hard on um both
in a 2017 nerves paper and also we've
updated it with a new and improved
version in an archive paper
last year that should hopefully come out
very soon
and
in practice this also seems a little bit
complicated to estimate and if you
actually used classical approaches to
estimate this it is a bit challenging to
work out all the math and all the
gradients and everything
but in practice actually you can
efficiently approximate this by a deep
supervised autumn cutter so we can use
deep learning to approximate the system
actually quite efficiently and the code
actually doesn't
it's not too bad when you're using
modern machine learning frameworks
so i don't really have time to go too
deep into exactly how all this works i
instead really wanted to say this is
what we're doing
now how can we actually use this in
practice and i want to take you through
a case study
so we're going to look at a case study
of social behavior and we're going to be
looking at a two-chamber social
interaction test so we have a what i'm
showing you here in the top left we have
a freely um behaving mouse
and it has two chambers that it can go
into it has a social chamber in the
object chamber and then within the
social chamber there is a friendly mouse
and it can choose to interact with a
social friendly mouse and that's just
measured by if it comes within a radius
of the friendly mouse or it can choose
to perform an object interaction which
just happens when it becomes within the
radius of the object
now these mites are
in general
typically prefer social interaction
these are wild type mice so they're
going to typically prefer social
interaction and so we have this question
can we use these machine learning
approaches and
actually take all this local field
potential data that we have
and predict whether we are having a
social interaction or an object
interaction an answer is yes so on the
bottom right we're just showing you that
we can get area under the curves way
above chance
and we're proud of that but this is not
what makes our method so unique so i'm
not going to actually spend too much
time on that i'm going to focus instead
on what exactly
makes our model unique and how we're
going to use it as a result of this data
and so just real quickly what we're
actually doing here
is we're going to use that electro model
that i conceptually introduced we're
going to take all of our data we're
going to map it to a neural network
encoder that's going to approximate
easily in source so we can do this
really fast in practice because it's
just a neural network to approximate the
inverse problem
and
one thing that's actually critical is
when we're doing this well we actually
have some information right when we're
training it we know whether it was an
object interaction or a social
interaction so rather than just training
this into what's called an unsupervised
objective we use that unsupervised
objective which is just can we explain
the neural data we observed and also we
require that our
latent scores are predictive of behavior
and we encourage that through standard
cross-entropy losses that i'm not going
to go into too much
so one of the things that's really
important for interpretability is not
that we use every single electron right
if i'm saying there's one electron
that's going to represent social
activity well we can limit it to say we
want you to be able to predict the
behavior but only with a single electron
and that's really what we do in practice
so this is the system we're using here
it uses the speed and efficiency of
modern deep learning approaches but it
really maintains the electron
interpretability
so let's actually look at the electron
that came out of this so we found our
one electron network that's actually
really good at predicting whether you're
in a social interaction or an object
interaction
um and we we're going to test everything
now down the line by doing more objects
and social interaction tests
and we're going to say well this is what
the electron looks like and i'm not
going to look at every single detail
here but i do want to know there are
several frequency bands but we found
that the most dominant frequency band in
this electron network was in the 4 to 11
hertz so in the 4 to 11 hertz we can
look at the drivers but it looks like
the key drivers of this network are the
amygdala the pre-olympic cortex and the
infra-limbic cortex and the 4-11 hertz
band
now this is our social network and i'm
going to talk a little bit about what
we're going to do with it but before i
do that i just want to show you that
this really is capturing relevant
behavior so i'm showing you the scores
here as an event triggered average on
our social activity so when a mouse
engages in a social interaction we can
show what's happening with our en social
network activity or those network scores
so it engages in social activity it goes
up a lot and then at the end of an
interaction you can see that you're
actually tapering the network before the
end of the interaction
and we're showing two networks here in
green is our en social that's our social
lecture network and then we have an
object electron network as well that
would signify whether you're in an
object interaction or not
so this is really capturing it there's a
pretty wide band here that's standard
error over mice because we just don't
have that many mice it's a kind of a
wide box but this is really strong
evidence that this network really is
capturing social interactions in the
data
so now the big question here
is
is this real right
i've explained
a conceptual network model of the brain
um it's a pretty complicated model and
there's a lot of data and math that i
didn't show you behind it and i've told
you that it can predict whether a mouse
is in a social or non-social interaction
so if i were to go a neurostar to go to
present to neuroscientists they tend to
be a little bit skeptical because
they're going to say well what evidence
do you really have that this is in fact
a network related to social activity and
in fact my collaborator kathleen deraza
used to always ask me is this real why
should i trust you and more importantly
how can we test whether this is real or
not these are really super legitimate
questions and they are questions that i
think we really need to engage with as
computational people and really this
comes to the the point that i was
starting my talk with how can we treat
the artificial intelligence or machine
learning method as a collaborator to
design confirmatory experiments
so let's think about what we want to do
well we want this model to generalize we
want this model to be able to decode new
animals
right so if we say get a new animal and
we say this is your social network we
want that to actually work on new
animals so we're going to collect new
animals and just make sure that it works
really well we want to link be able to
be linked to interpretable biology
across levels of analysis
so we want to see that this holds up
across different scales of analysis
right we're looking at kind of the
mesoscale here where we're looking at
local field potentials these are
invasive measurements but they're not
individual neurons so we want to
actually see in this context that these
electron networks correspond to what's
going on in individual neurons which are
the considered real drivers of neural
activity and behavior in the brain and
third it should work in new behavioral
contexts and if it starts to do all
these things where we can say it links
to interpretable biology it works in new
animals it works in lots of different
contexts we're going to start getting a
lot more evidence that this may be a
fundamental principle
so i want to show you a little bit of
what we've done on that so far
so first there's this question of does
this generalize to new mice well because
we have trained this uh neural network
encoder this is a really easy thing to
test we go and collect new mice we run
it to estimate our
electron activity scores and then we
just check to see what they're doing and
so we ran this on 28 new mice and
basically the results hold up exactly as
you expect them to
i'm not going to say too much more about
this because what i think is a lot more
interesting is we really want to know
whether individual neurons correspond to
our electron models so as i mentioned in
the beginning when we implant these
wires into the brain we don't just get
just electrons and through these local
field potentials we're also able to
collect a lot of neural action
potentials
through a lot of different brain cells
and we get these all over the brain
and so what we did here is we said well
if we look at all these brain cells
can we actually check whether these
brain cells whether they're firing rates
are correlated to electrome network
activity
and so we started by just looking at the
social network and what you find is that
17.5 of all the cells we measured were
strongly correlated
with um en social activity
so actually
nearly one in five cells is actually
correlated with what's going on in this
network so they are actually linking to
networks and just as a note i'm just
showing whether a cell corresponds to
the social network activity here not
whether it's corresponding to any electo
so if you look at whether a neuron is
correlated with any of our electron
networks the number is actually above 50
corrected for multiple comparisons
so these neurons really are strongly
correlated with our electron models
well and given that we think that these
things are actually tied to neural
activity and we have an inf we have this
idea of how we think information is
flowing in this electron network
this says that well can we actually up
regulate this
based on a hypothesis that well
if we have more a electron network
social activity so if we increase the
activity of that late network it's also
going to increase your social presence
if you have
more this network more strongly
expressed you're going to have
more desire to be social so we can do
this well
what we can say is well we know that
they're actually related to neurons this
is actually strongly correlated with
neurons so if we had that well and we
know that it's coming out of these brain
regions in particular the strongest
leader here
in our computational models of the
prelimbic cortex we can actually say
go and use optogeogenic optogenetic
stimulation techniques where we can take
the neurons that start in the preolympic
cortex with terminals and the nucleus
accumbens and we can stimulate them at
10 hertz and this 10 hertz is chosen
based upon the fact that in this
electron we found that this was
a very dominant band at the 4 to 11
hertz frame so we can actually say well
premade cortex is leading this it's
leading us based on a 10 hertz frequency
band let's stimulate these neurons at 10
hertz to try to up regulate this network
and so the answer is
what happens when this uh works and i'm
sorry about the uh there looks to be a
rendering error here but this is saying
if we do pre-olympic cortex to nucleus
accomplish stimulation the first thing
we wanted to do
was we wanted to check
does this actually enhance
network activation so if we can estimate
our
social electron scores
what exactly happens well
what happens here is that when we use a
control condition which is a yellow
laser that's not designed to respond to
the neurons so it's just the control
condition we see no change in the social
network activity scores
and
when we use a blue laser that is
designed to stimulate these neurons and
match with the optogenetic technique it
actually strongly increases the social
activity scores so we're actually up
regulating this network as far as we can
measure it by using this optogenetic
technique and not only that we see
significant changes in the amount of
social behavior that these mice are
engaging in so if we look at whether
how much they're choosing to freely
interact with the social condition
it's significantly increased
under the
target condition rather than concur the
control condition and when we're looking
at does it change our object
interactions we really don't get an
effect
now if you want to be a little bit
pessimistic here you can actually say
well maybe you're just stimulating the
right pathways right so maybe it's just
the fact that you have this first brain
region the second brain region both have
been implicated in social behavior
before so maybe we just needed to
stimulate that pathway to get this
behavioral change
and you're not necessarily using the
electron so to kind of get the question
of well how much does the electron
really matter here well we're going to
say we're going to look at 20 hertz and
10 hertz 10 hertz within our model and
20 hertz with not
well what we find is that 10 hertz
across the board it actually increases
the social
activity scores of those electron scores
much more it's up regularly in the
network much more
and the behavior is also dramatically
differently increased in the social
interaction so when you do 20 hertz
which doesn't show up on our election we
don't get the same results so it really
does
seem to matter that we're using the
frequencies and bridge regions that we
found in this election
so just to conclude um i have a ton more
data that i can show you here um a lot
of this data is in a bio archive
pre-print
but to really emphasize the key point of
today
i strongly believe that we should be
using machine learning models as
collaborators in experimental design by
using data-driven hypotheses this is
what we're working on
um and i particularly want to
acknowledge the nih for funding to
support this work i have a brain theory
and methods grant that supported much of
the algorithm and method development
used to generate these results and my
research group is continually working to
improve these methods i really would
like to thank kaffwe de raza i'm a
collective for psychiatric
neuroengineering
who performed all the experiments here
that we used our methods on and i do
want to give particular notes that
austin talbot and neil gallagher both
contributed heavily to the computational
methods both recently completed their
phds and are moving on to other
institutions
just a few key references here and thank
you so much for your attention